in most of our videos you seem in my
office sometimes in the lab we're
looking at molecules usually collect
small ones or elements how they react
what happens now
it's a bit different today we're in the
field surrounded by yellow flowers these
are flowers that have been grown as a
crop to make oil
it's called oil seed rape so what do i
is the chemist see when I look at these
flowers and plants
I see their yellow I have no idea why
they're yellow but obviously it's quite
an a complicated organic compound and I
see the leaves which are green I know
that those are due to chlorophyll that's
compound of magnesium again it's really
quite complicated it's enough
chlorophyll in the leaf to capture the
energy of the Sun and use that to split
up water into hydrogen and oxygen and
react the hydrogen with the carbon
dioxide in the air to make organic
compounds I'm here because I'm
interested in taking this carbon dioxide
that the plant has captured and thinking
how could we use those chemicals that
are in the plant to turn them into
something that's useful that I as a
chemist could use at the lab or could be
used in chemical manufacture to make
things that are useful for us sometimes
chemicals are used from plants already
sugar is used various different sorts of
sugars they're fermented to make alcohol
either to drink or sometimes to be used
industrially in fact you can make
alcohol without ever going near a plant
the difference between alcohol that you
get in a plant and the one that you get
from a chemical factory is the one in
the plant is slightly radioactive
because there's radioactive carbon in
the air and in fact in America you can't
sell wine or beer if it's not
radioactive because it means it's got
industrial alcohol in it and not alcohol
from plants what we want as chemists is
to use more of the plant not just a few
seeds or a bit of sugar it's a huge
problem had to do this so what we've got
to do is get a lot of chemists working
together and I and my colleague here in
Nottingham Simon Woodward a part of a
network of chemists all around Europe
who working together to think what are
the best way
that we can start unlocking these
chemicals and we've started the network
called new biochem utilizing biomass
biomass means plants use it utilizing
biomass for chemicals so that we can try
and coordinate our research so
everybody's work interlinked together
the thing that chemists want to do is
really to do with plants what they do
with oil at the moment with oil
petroleum it comes out of the ground and
goes into a refinery and the refinery
makes lots of different products makes
transport fuel it makes chemicals so
chemists have come up with the idea of a
bio refinery where a plant goes in and
out of this bio refinery comes lots of
different products some which can be
used for making chemicals some which may
products may actually be energy for
making heat for making electricity and
some of it will be fuels so to replace
some of the oil that we used at the mint
for transport people quite a lot of
people are really plants the way forward
to make chemicals and the answer is that
the only source of carbon that we're
sure that we're going to have in the
unlimited future is carbon dioxide at
the moment plants are by far the best
way of capturing carbon dioxide from the
air in the future I'm sure that chemists
will discover other ways of capturing
carbon dioxide but it's going to take a
long time before you can capture as much
carbon dioxide as you can in this field
as simply as just by growing seeds in
the ground and adding a little
fertilizer in the end like many of these
problems we're going to need a
combination of them but there's a real
chemical challenge how to turn my plants
into chemicals and that's something
which we need to start answering now